des statues des tableaux et même des
épées ce sont en tout 350 objets à la
mémoire de napoléon 1er qui sont réunis
depuis ce week end au château de
fontainebleau
une collection exceptionnelle qui
matérialise la vie et les derniers
instants de celui qui a conquis une
grande partie de l'europe pour y porter
le fer de la révolution là vous avez les
derniers effets personnels de napoléon
1er est notamment anne ces derniers
mouchoirs on peut également voir des
traces de sang ce qui était très
caractéristique de la fin de sa vie de
sa maladie et les bandelettes de le club
si parmi les pièces rares qui seront
aussi mises aux enchères mercredi et
jeudi des manuscrits son légendaire
chapeau le traîneau de joséphine ou
encore les bas de l'officier
d'artillerie devenu empereur en soi des
bas de soie
vous avez toujours cette petite bande
brodé ici
et toujours pleine couronnée de napoléon
bien que la date du 5 mai pourrait faire
grimper les enchères
certains tableaux figurines et livres de
cette exposition sont estimées à moins
de 150 euros
de quoi combler de nombreux amateurs de
la grande épopée napoléonienne